Ірина Васильченко показуючи маршрут
своїх під зброєю знову личкове містечко
яка з на сході України
дівчачі розбої вигляді та по успіхам
виїхала до Росії спочатку в
краснодарський край чомусь москву однак
залежний місяців жити а співаючий краї не
вона так вона змогла знати а я не роботу а
його форми ти документи оформлення
документів коштують дуже дорого оформлення
документів дещо і навіть дорогу а я і
так на мою гарну забула на реальну а
ось що якщо на роботу точно ринок
хочеш приладу особі і на весь шлях він
це до перспективи нахабно що увала я
сказала все підуть аридній Україні дуже
влаштовувало я сказала я поїду у свою
рідну країну міг її вечора з
бюрократичним кагани ну та допоможуть
владова над dutch ікалося мусала збір
то сивого ланти або народити таких
центрів пит ринку або шеф києві кілька
десят Олександр горбатко гривні кухнею і
з вірменських організацій та пари canon ij
допомогу біженцям надають за родом 7
волонтери вона український дорж структурою
колосальну суму який виділяється на
смітник код що і виділяються на видного
нежити
інфраструктури алое не бачу реальні
зради ситуації
проблемою яку було таке завершилося
тобто проблема як була так і є за
офіційними даними та в Україні нора
zippo над pittura мільйона хлопчак
переселенців за рідних шаману
пенсіонерів та дітей
150 тисяч людей хоче завищує якщо їх
на цю роботу Києву в українській службі
зайнятості або знаєте вона вас худа вони
хороший вони вакансії
на сьогоднішній день це катастрофа на
сьогодні щось катастрофічного лика киргиз
людей і переїхав і їх науки на зуби
стукають і робочими місцями у нас закладу
ну виси мільярдів нових старша
5 мільярдів мільярдів з цих лікував
проблеми біженців ірена ви вирішила до
допомагати і пара салон team почала
проти те в одному з волонтерських
центрів
all і наведи бла що ваші сік і чи мун
омрі я повернувся шкідливим місцем